have you ever heard that the Hoover Dam
which finished construction on March 1st
1936 is still drying is there any truth
to the statement and if so how has the
Hoover Dam been able to be used safely
over the past several decades well the
answer to this question is maybe as we
really don't know engineers expect that
with the conventional method of drying
the Hoover Dam would take 125 years to
fully dry so technically the Hoover Dam
shouldn't be completely dry till 2061
but the thing is during the construction
engineers implemented various techniques
that would speed up the drying process
of the Hoover Dam like filling the dam
up with water which actually ironically
helps but we aren't exactly sure how
effective these processes are especially
given the large-scale implementation so
unfortunately we don't exactly know if
it is fully dry or not but it is quite
likely that is still in process of
curing however even if the Hoover Dam is
fully cured the process would have taken
several decades to do so so how have we
been able to use it safely all this time
well looking back at the history of the
dam the plan was originally developed by
the US Bureau of Reclamation about a
century ago they proposed building a dam
along the Arizona Nevada border in order
to both harness power from the Colorado
River and direct water to developing
agricultural regions see at this time
the population the Southwest was very
low and just trying to pick up compared
to the rest of the US so this project
was meant to boost immigration and
settlement in the area the plan was
originally proposed to Congress in 1922
with the price tag of 49 million dollars
or about 700 million dollars in today's
money Herbert Hoover really wanted to
build this dam in 1922 which was
initially called the boulder dam as this
would direct water to seven nearby
states but this was met with a lot of
opposition in fact it wouldn't be till
1928 that President Calvin Coolidge who
authorized a project eventually
construction began in 1931 and
throughout the process 4.3 million
backyards or 868 million gallons of
concrete will be required to build a
monstrosity in the end the Hoover Dam
would come out to weigh six point six
million tons capable of handling forty
five thousand pounds per square foot of
pressure but how was a drying dam able
to cope with that much pressure well as
I mentioned before the water in the DIMM
actually helps a concrete to cure a
common misconception with concrete is
that oftentimes people think that cement
dries as a water in the mixture of BAP
rates but this is not true
evaporation is just a physical change
but the curing of concrete is a chemical
change in reality as concrete cures
water molecules are integrated on a
microscopic level where they form
crystals which helps to bind the wet
cement and form concrete this process of
forming crystals by slowly binding the
water molecules to the tricalcium
silicate molecules in the cement deform
concrete is what takes several decades
but letting it cool naturally was not
only time intensive but also dangerous
you see during this process of curing a
lot of heat is released by the chemical
reaction of cement occurring at the
concrete as this is an exothermic
reaction or basically a reaction that
dissipates heat the concern with this is
that as he is released the inside of the
dam will be much hotter than the surface
of the dam as heat essentially gets
trapped within the dam over time this
could lead to cracks and weakened the
dam as a result the solution to this
conundrum was to make a network of
cooling pipes with circulating water
within the dam to cool it down by the
end of construction over 600 miles of
pipe would be embedded within the dam
and fun fact you can actually still see
these pipes within certain deep
galleries in the dam while this entire
process may sound foreign you have
probably seen it being implemented
around you and you just never realized
one of the most common places this
process is used is the curing of the
plaster on an in-ground pool it takes 10
to 12 months for the interior plaster
finish inside of a
to fully cure but of course we don't see
homeowners or businesses waiting nearly
this long to fill up their pool in fact
you can fill up your pool that day this
plaster is applied as a water will just
help to cure it around 60% of the curing
for a pole will happen within the first
28 days and the remaining 40% will
happen over the next eight to ten months
and this is why the first month or so in
operation you'll find crystals on the
Florida pool its technical term is
plaster dust and this is the same
process we saw in the Hoover Dam as a
plaster on the pool cures crystal form
which helps fill and solidify the new
finish as the Hoover Dam is
exponentially larger than a regular pool
it takes an exponential longer time to
cure in the end the Hoover Dam may very
well still be curing but this is not a
concern as a water blocked by a dam is
just helping a cure initially the dam
was not filled until it was starting off
to handle pressure of the water but
after that step was crossed the water
only helps and the thing is many
scientists say that concrete actually
never fully occurs and it simply just
keeps getting stronger with time so even
past the expected 125 year timeframe the
Hoover Dam won't be completely cured but
by then and even now the vast majority
has already dried and there are
absolutely no safety concerns but given
this extensive drying process it's no
wonder whoever dam is expected to be one
of the few structures he'll survive
thousands of years past our existence if
you guys thought this video explain the
drying process of the Hoover Dam well
then make sure drop a like and consider
subscribing you flexi more questions
just like this one logically answered
but until then I'm party and I'll see
you guys on the next one
[Music]